it's tough me an Indiana basketball
player I get confused with Larry Bird
all the time
what's up everybody this is big tall the
deeper the Indiana Pacers I'm pretty
good at basketball not so good at comedy
but tonight I'm going to try some
stand-up let's see how it go is this
Michael okay there we go
I saw I recently did a song with to
change out of the 2 Chainz I did called
rope-a-dope it was kind of weird for me
though you know when it happened walked
in before five change and I was only
expecting to thank you know a guy right
so you made a record with two chains
called the rope-a-dope it was like a
boxing analogy no your basketball player
who sings about boxing your whole life
is mr. radish yeah I like that I like
that you were good you all right you
know I mean it was I didn't know I think
that you just got to stand in it more
you got just project be confident
picture that stage leg you know and when
you plan and in the playoffs or
something
you know I remember going to my dad and
my dad was a little different he wasn't
really a basketball fan when were going
to him and saying no I just got a full
scholarship to Indiana University I
think that's where I want to go and he
said no I don't think so yeah I want you
to go to China and study martial arts
and become a martial artist so you can
have a sound body in a cell mud around
I'll probably be the darkest Karate Kid
you have ever seen if you know why God
be Will Smith's son and then meet right
here black and some bells at night you
probably couldn't even see me during the
nighttime but it is what it is I want
you to relate to these people you
already got the presents but just stand
behind them jokes when you get on that
stage grab that mic let the people know
who you are you know me and just just
give it to think of me when it's not
going right you know you going right I
mean growing up you know I know with a
singer and my friends knew but a lot of
people didn't know they used to tell me
to I'll give you five dollars and you
get five dollars if you go get that
girl's number but you got to sing it to
her so I used to go to them and I used
to be like excuse me miss can I please
get your number
[Applause]